[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
émission 7 8 le débat manger plus
d'oeufs bio à la cantine
une idée qui séduit de nombreux parents
d'élèves est également certains élus en
ce moment l'assemblée nationale débat
des modalités pour imposer une
proportion minimum de produits bio ou
respectueux de l'environnement au sein
dé restauration collective publique
si le candidat emmanuel macron avait
promis qu'un produit sur deux serait bio
en 2022
cette révolution dans les assiettes se
confronte à de nombreuses difficultés le
bio pèse aujourd'hui environ 3% des
produits manger dans la restauration
scolaire
alors est-ce réellement possible
d'augmenter la part de bio 100 des
cantines scolaires et pourquoi est ce si
difficile à mettre en place pour
répondre à ces questions j'accueille
autour de moi corinne essertel
présidente du conseil local des parents
d'élèves de la fcpe de
montigny-le-bretonneux suzanne blanc
adjointe à la vie scolaire à
montigny-le-bretonneux et anne capio
adjointe à l'éducation et au
périscolaire d'elancourt
et peut-être que durant ce débat du
seront rejoints par madame bénédicte
rébé roth qui s'approche vous êtes
responsable du développement des
territoires au groupement agriculture
biologique de la région ile de france
bonsoir à vous tous et merci à tous deux
sont ici pour ce débat alors aujourd'hui
le bio semble faire consensus au sein de
la société civile par exemple vous dans
vos deux collectivités quelle est la
proportion justement des repas bio au
sein des cantines scolaires
alors en ce qui concerne la mairie dit
long cours nous avons un repas bio sur
les cinq composantes bio sur les cinq
composantes ainsi une fois par mois
d'accord sur cinq composantes qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça et bien l'entrée le
plein le fromage le dessert et et
l'accompagnement d'accord aruba bio au
complet au complet un par mois
voilà corps qui est annoncé sur les
menus qui sont distribués aux familles
on voit monter leur côté montini nous
avons à chaque fois qu'il s'agit d'un
fruits en dessert
il s'agit d'un free bio d'accord donc
100% des desserts fruités qui se serrent
biologique d'accord je parle des fruits
je parle pas des compotes d'accord
développement des fruits
il faut jouer on va dire des fruits
frais très bien vous notamment comme
j'expliquais vous êtes donc que
présidente de la fcpe de
montigny-le-bretonneux vous avez
notamment lancé une pétition qui a
récolté 500 signatures pour demander
davantage aux produits bio locaux pour
coup pourquoi justement est ce que pour
vous ça ne vous satisfait pas d'avoir
uniquement des uniquement pour avoir des
produits le fit le fooding idiot on
abonde en fait le produit bio c'est
important pour les enfants parce que
c'est mais enfin les produits ont plus
de goût
qu'est ce qu'ils sont de saison et donc
ça développe le goût pour les enfants à
qui ça apprend aussi qu'il ya des
saisons dans les fruits on mange pas des
espaces des bana toute l'année ou
ivresse décembre voilà c'est ça donc
c'est pour respecter après le
l'environnement etc c'est pour d'accord
non plus par pour l'éducation au goût
que vous souhaitez avoir plus de bio
fund et puis bon après c'est aussi
meilleur pour la santé des visites ou
les pesticides surtout pour les enfants
qui sont en pleine croissance
d'accord est-ce que vous il ya une
volonté politique justement pour
augmenter la part de bio au sein des
cantines scolaires
alors en ce qui concerne elancourt je
peux pas parler de volonté politique non
d'accord - dopantes et le bjp ou non on
ne sait pas une volonté politique
d'accord vous n'avez pas des parents
d'élèves ou des versions afin qu'ils se
mobilisent pour avoir essayé d'avoir
plus de bio non alors assuré long cours
pour l'instant pas peut-être que
l'émission va susciter des envies
d'accord mais pour l'instant non on n'a
pas on n'a pas spécialement c'est vrai
qu'on se rend compte que les parents
d'élèves s'intéressent de plus en plus à
ce que leurs enfants mangent à la
cantine
donc on entend par ci par là des
demandes de jus de menus végétariens et
végétaliens de nu bio devenu sans viande
ça devient un peu compliqué à gérer au
niveau des collectivités
d'accord ce qui alors se démentir sa
demande de parents de leurs on arrive on
arrive notre marché actuel arrive à son
terme
donc l'appel d'offres a été lancé bien
sûr pour renouveler ou pas l'actuel
prestataire pas nous verrons au nid au
niveau des réponses et c'est vrai que
bien évidemment quand on est tous
conscients et j'entends tout à fait ce
que nous dit madame issartel on est tous
conscient des progrès que nous avons à
faire des circuits de cours des produits
locaux etc
sachez quand même que montigny d'ores et
déjà on a malgré tout de la viande de
lapin
poulet label rouge la viande française
la pêche les poissons issus de la pêche
responsable voilà il ya quand même un
certain nombre de choses qui ont été
prises en compte je ne dis pas que ça
fait du tout bio je dis simplement que
en plus les poissons je doute qu'on a un
jour la possibilité d'avoir une position
entièrement bio sauf à les élever mais
voilà ça c'était là la petite parenthèse
s'adapte à montigny-le-bretonneux vous
êtes sensibles notamment la question
d'augmenter là je crois qu'on est
sensible comme tout le monde bien
évidemment soit alors il faut considérer
les choses bien sûr qu'on a pris en
compte
la pétition qui enferme d'après ans
quand on a eu connaissance de la
pétition qui a été qui a été lancé on
était déjà de toute façon avait abordé
ces sujets puisque on fait des réunions
avec les fédérations de parents d'élèves
deux fois par an à la rentrée en règle
générale puis un petit peu plus tard
dans l'année
donc voilà ça on en est conscient après
faut se poser d'autres questions aussi
son qui n'était peut-être pas dans vos
questions donc je vais je vais de lancer
les choses mais là aussi il ya aussi une
question de coût malheureusement oui le
nerf de la guerre c'est toujours
l'argent
et donc à l'heure actuelle nous sommes à
1 euro 20 nouvelles puisque on en
applique 4 quotient nous sommes à nous
allons 2,1 euros 24 à 3 euros 3 euros
sur 15 ou 45 voilà le repas selon le
selon le quotient
malheureusement vous savez que les
dotations d'état ce sens qu'elles sont à
l'heure actuelle on veut devenir ce
qu'elles vont devenir aussi donc
forcément qui dit tout bio d'il ya un
coût supplémentaire de légumes ou du
pain on peut essayer d'aller voilà étape
par étape
on peut aller étape par étape je vous
entends bien madame issartel on peut
aller étape par étape mais ça ça fait
quand même partie des choses qu'il faut
prendre en compte aussi voie d'accord
est-ce que ce que forcément le yacht et
les en ce moment plus cher en fait c'est
parce que si le fatah disais justement
pour les collectivités territoriales
alors effectivement le coût des produits
bio souvent est plus élevé que des
produits conventionnels en saas est liée
principalement aux coûts de production
qu'ils sont du plus important bio une
des raisons à ça c'est le désherbage en
fait nan en bio n'utilise pas de
désherbant chimique
donc il faut désherber soit manuellement
donc c'est de la main d'oeuvre soit
mécaniquement donc avec des outils
particuliers ça prend beaucoup plus de
temps bien sûr elle critique au oui non
mais donc je n'ai effectivement après
c'est vrai que 1
ce qu'il faut voir aussi c'est que dans
le coût d'un repas il ya à peu près un
quart seulement qui est le coût matière
et les trois-quarts masse et le coût du
personnel qui prépare les repas c'est le
coup de panneaux et un euro à 3 euros le
coût le wagon
7h50 oui voilà ça ne sais pas du tout ce
que l'on applique aux fans nico et non
ce que dira c'est le coût matière le
poids la fête d'achat des produits ça
représente enfin à peu près un quart du
coût total du repas le prix de revient
donc après effectivement si
le produit bio est un peu plus cher au
final sur le coût total du repas
l'augmentation est moins net c'est ça
que je voulais dire et donc après il ya
un certain nombre de leviers qu'on peut
utiliser justement pour essayer de
remédier à ce front là du coup ça peut
être justement va souvent les
collectivités qui s'engagent dans ses
démarches la travaille aussi sur la
réduction du gaspillage
parce qu'il ya souvent centenaires
dessous de ce pillage voilà donc en fait
on réfléchit ce temps là dessus comment
on peut réduire le gaspillage et du coup
faire des économies de matières
premières ça permet de faire des
économies qu'on peut utiliser ensuite
pour acheter des produits bio
il ya aussi des petites astuces on va
dire par exemple sur dans les cantines
des selfs c'est d'éviter de mettre le
pain en début de chaîne parce que les
enfants mangent du pain large du pain et
après au final dimanche plus vraiment si
la masia tc jetez donc ça déjà rien
qu'en mettant le pain en scène voilà
regardant la solution peut être qu'ainsi
il ya effectivement vous avez parlé tout
à l'heure des menus végétariens qui
peuvent se mettre en place de manière
par exemple tous les quinze jours
ça permet juno raison d'économiser un
peu sur le coût de la viande qui est un
produit assez cher enfin voilà il ya
cinq ans mais dans le marigot s'il ya
quand même une augmentation indirecte
mais qu'il est possible de réduire sa
avec une autre gestion enfin le voilà
c'est ça d'accord avec des skis ce qui
me semble aussi important a précisé au
niveau du coût des repas
bon nous à elancourt on a cette caution
donc ça va de 54 centimes à 4 euros 12
civils avec l'escouade et conscience
ces négociants salon les ressources de
la famille quand il ya un quotient qui
est seul le budget et donc donc de 54
centimes à quatre roues 12 et il faut
savoir que nous sur elancourt un repas
revient alors coûts matières plus
personnel etc revient à 12 euros et
qu'elle vend voilà en arrondissant à 13
euros
donc la différence entre les 54 centimes
et les 13 euros
c'est la mairie qui compense voilà donc
le souci c'est que même et vous avez
raison le en fait l'augmentation
représente un quart de ce prix mais
c'est déjà beaucoup pour les familles
on s'en rend compte il ya des familles
qui ont du mal à payer leurs factures en
paiement donc si on a on n'a pas d'autre
solution que d'augmenter les prix et
augmenter les prix aujourd'hui eva est
une nécessité pour les collectivités si
on inclut le bio si on introduit le bio
dans les cantines
parce que comme disait même blanc la dgf
qui baisse la taxe d'habitation qu'on ne
touchera plus bientôt etc
ça commence à être compliquée et les
familles sont aussi impactés par par les
impôts et et toutes les charges qui
arrive donc je suis pas sûr que ce soit
le bon timing
voyez pour annoncer du bio avec une
augmentation des prix qui de toute façon
sera inévitable une solution d'augmenter
le quotient familial pour les familles
les plus aisées pour en guise de
solidarité est ce que c'est un débat que
vous avez eu cette discussion il ya une
suppression d'un composant dans les
menus donc comme on expliqué ya les
composants ses entrées plats etc
il ya récemment il ya une diminution
d'un composant
on repas et au goûter mais le prix est
resté le même mais c'est donc on
pourrait profiter mais on pourrait
profiter de ce gap pour justement
augmenter la part de bio vu que l'appel
d'offres va être ne nous étions pas
justement de votre conversation pourquoi
ce que justement vous avez alors ne
soyons pas quelqu'un aborder le
gaspillage je crois que c'est vous
madame
en l'occurrence le prestataire que nous
avons nous a signalé moult fois et donc
on avait un bilan effectivement de tout
ce qui été gaspillé alors ce n'est pas
faute d'attention des animateurs qui
font ce qu'ils peuvent pour que pour
essayer déjà de faire goûter d'un
président de vous le savez et c'était à
goûter aux enfants que tout ne soit pas
gâché que il nous est arrivé il nous
arrive d'aller déjeuner sur les cantines
et on a on n'a pas tout les continents
en chef
on en a on en a deux et je me suis
trouvé une fois derrière un petit garçon
qui avait défini de déjeuner et qui
avait des tas de choses sur son plateau
qui n'a pas mangé son yaourt que ses
pairs qui n'étaient pas ouverts même pas
et là je dis mais pourquoi tu as pris
toute sa part à l'abri donc ce
gaspillage en a voulu y remédier ce qui
fait que haut niveau
alors au lieu d'avoir par exemple viseur
de tout cela on fait un fromage et un
dessert
on a maintenant soit un jour avec une
entrée et pas de fromage sous un jour
avec fromage n'est pas d'entrer et de
toute façon un aliment est rajouté voir
le grammage des légumes et plus
important est un aliment évidemment on
va pas mettre 120 g de fromage dans les
carottes râpées mais c'est comme ça que
les choses ont été entendus ça n'a guère
changé
le coût de revient en tout cas et donc
voilà donc ça c'est on a déjà un très
bon bilan je prends les chiffres en tête
mais on a déjà un très bon bilan par
rapport à ça puisqu'on a fait des pesées
du coup si on les écoles et ça marche et
c'est bien aussi d'éveiller les enfants
à ça alors moi je voudrais un tout petit
peu puisqu'on a la chance de vous avoir
madame je crois qu'il ya bien sûr qu'on
se pose la question mettre plus de bio
etc
c'est bien et je pense qu'il ya une
espèce de petite révolution à faire au
niveau peut-être du tandem que vous
pourriez formé avec les prestataires qui
sont ceux qui se présentent
voilà dans les faits le problème
justement des appels d'offres avant
d'aborder la question je voudrais
reposer ma question un parent d'élève
parce que vous acceptez de voir le prix
justement de la cantine augmenté pour
avoir du bio après augmenté je suis pas
sûr que les parents acceptent sera
augmentée il faudrait il faudrait sondés
il faudrait sondés pour me demander si
quelques lequel par l augmentation ils
seraient ils seraient prêts à voilà où
qu elles varient très près
apprendre de la poche l'instant il n'y a
pas eu de négociation là dessus on n'a
pas du tout discuté durant plus de
cinquante d'accord je le disais
précédemment
en ce qui nous concerne l'appel d'offres
est en cours donc voilà ça bref on va
falloir qu'on attende
est-ce que vous pouvez nous rappeler qu
est-ce qu qu'est ce qu'un appel d'offres
et quelles sont les conditions et bien
en règle générale un prestataire est
choisi pour un certain nombre d'années
au nom de la renouveler une fois par an
c'est donc c'est sur trois ans
renouvelables et puis là le marché est
arrivé à terme et donc à partir de
janvier on aura un nouveau prestataire
ou le même mais voilà et donc il était
établi un cahier des charges dans ce
cahier des charges un certain nombre de
choses qui sont notifiés et auquel les
prestataires doivent répondre après une
analyse qui est faite de ces réponses
c'est donc là justement y avait un
somptueux il ya beaucoup justement de
marché de petits exploitants bio qui
n'est pas les moyens qu'ils ont du mal à
répondre justement sésame et ne doivent
pas pour pourquoi justement de livraison
dont on n'a pas de cuisine sur place en
ce qui me concerne par exemple à
elancourt non plus attrape une cuisine
centrale ville mais pas nous donc un
producteur ne peut pas partir de chez
lui avec ses poireaux et carottes et
venir les livrets brut de fonderie
pardon du terme dans les cantines
donc de toute façon il ya un processus
de deux failles un procédé de
d'élaboration voilà qui prépare les
plats voilà et qui donne sens propre en
boîte en plastique corps notamment
effectivement un agriculteur tout seul
c'est très difficile de répondre aux
appels d'offres en une collectivité
parce qu'il faut souvent une grande
diversité de produits sur pas mal de
mois dans l'année c'est avec des des
contraintes assez forte mais donc au
niveau nous dû comprendre agriculteurs
bio il ya déjà plusieurs années on a on
a participé en fait à la création d'une
coopérative s'appelle la coopérative bio
d'île de france et qui regroupe
actuellement une quarantaine
d'agriculteurs bio de la région donc des
maraîchers des arboriculteurs des
agriculteurs on appelle ça des grandes
cultures qui font du coup des cultures
de légumes sur des plus grandes surfaces
on a aussi des éleveurs et donc ils se
sont regroupés pour justement pouvoir
proposer une offre s'est diversifiée
avec des volumes conséquents et être
visibles vis-à-vis des clients des
collectivités et donc cette coopérative
là elle est en mesure de répondre à des
appels d'offres elle a déjà remporter un
certain nombre d'appels d'offres
voilà deux lycées de communes de gros
syndicats qui font sur place
pas forcément il ya aussi
comment dire des prestataires vie aux
commandes
ou alors il ya les deux cas de figure en
fait la couverture est capable de livrer
soit des prestataires qui cuisinent pour
le nos collectivités
ou alors des cuisines centrales
directement sans passer par des
présentations des serveuses demandées
les deux les deux après c'est un peu
plus compliqué effectivement quand il me
reste à terre parce que c'est un
intermédiaire entre la collectivité et
la coopérative mais c'est possible aussi
mais après il faut justement au moment
où la collectivité rédige ses appels
d'offres il faut qu'elle réfléchisse à
ce qu'elle commet comment faire pour que
justement cette coopérative bio puisse
répondre parce qu'effectivement en ile
de france on va pas voir de bananes de
citron on aura des tomates pas tout de
suite c'est donc on n'a pas non plus
tous les produits disponibles que vous
utilisez mais on en a quand même
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de légumes de
saison dévoué des produits laitiers des
légumes secs du pain alors pas forcément
directement par la coopérative mais il
ya des gros boulanger qui livre la
restauration scolaire et donc en fait
voilà on ya vraiment possibilité de
créer de ce qu'on appelle des lots c'est
à dire des groupes de produits et auquel
en fait la coopérative pourra répondre
et vous proposer du coût des produits
qui sont adaptés pour la restauration
cette année à tokyo
alors effectivement nous nous par
exemple dans notre marché on avait mis
une contrainte qui était un minimum de
40 % de produits locaux
voilà qui devait il devait venir de
l'agriculteur
si possible des yvelines mais en tout
cas de l'île de france
voilà et moi j'ai une question à vous
poser demain on rêve un peu fou pas si
on n'aime pas on va dire qu'on rêve et
on dit que toutes les écoles d'île de
france tous les collèges tous les lycées
passent au bio
comment on fait est ce que est ce que la
filière bio de l'ile-de-france jeu
suffirait à fournir les repas de
l'ensemble des cantines là j'ai pas
forcément je peux pas penser à vous
faire le calcul comme ça ce qu'il faut
voir c'est qu'effectivement on a
actuellement à la fois la production bio
qui se développe dans la région et la
demande aussi en restauration collective
il faut que ça se fasse de manière un
peu synchrone et de manière progressive
effectivement parce que
si effectivement demain tout le monde se
met à commander les produits bio et
c'est sûr qu'on pourra pas répondre du
jour au lendemain il faut que les choses
se fassent progressivement et ça c'est
justement le rôle de notre groupement
d'agriculteurs bio de sensibiliser de
forme et d'accompagner ces collectivités
de leur montrer les produits qui sont
les plus facilement disponibles
notre travail c'est aussi d'accompagner
des agriculteurs conventionnels à passer
en bio et à les conseiller justement sur
tel et tel type de culture donc et la
coopérative aussi travaille vraiment en
lien parce que dans la coopérative que
j'ai pas expliqué c'est que c'est un
statut de société coopérative d'intérêt
collectif et donc qui comprend plusieurs
collèges et donc il ya des collèges et
un collège agriculteurs et un collège
aussi collectivités un collège clients
un collège transformateurs distributeurs
et l'idée c'est justement dans cette
coopérative puisse y avoir tous ces
acteurs qui agissent ensemble pour
justement que cette adéquation se fasse
correctement et que voilà qu'on se
retrouve pas avec des des crises de
croissance comme
mais il ya aussi un autre souci c'est
que les parents d'élèves s'est jamais
repris vous demandez pas uniquement du
bio mais aussi d'autres de tous les
critères c'est bien ça pour
l'alimentation mais pour l'alimentation
oui tout à fait les produits locaux y
dédier plus de produits bio
d'accord mais aussi vous en plastique
oui bien sûr une autre passionnée de
cuisine et on a appris l'ap plus
particulièrement c'était les emballages
parce que des aliments qui sont préparés
dans des grandes cuisines après ils sont
dans des boîtes en plastique et ils sont
après réchauffer dans l'est
avant d'être servis sur les tables et
donc on sait que le plastique
aujourd'hui on ne sait pas comment il ya
beaucoup de doutes et dans le doute il
vaut mieux par principe de précaution
éliminer tous les plastiques
parce qu'on voit d'emblée phtalates ils
sont interdits dans les jouets est donc
là on voit que pour les enfants je pense
qu'ils ont moins un tout petit peu tous
les jours et donc multiplié par cinq
jours x toutes les semaines pendant que
ça ça vous inquiète
alors sois toi ce que j'allais ce que je
souhaite dire sur ce sujet je crois que
là aussi tout le monde est sensible à
cet argument
bien évidemment on n'a pas du tout envie
que nos enfants s'empoisonne petit à
petit d'une part malgré tout il va
falloir là aussi faire une petite
révolution au sein de nos cuisines et de
et des personnes qui préparent un qui
font réchauffer les barquettes en
question et puis voilà alors j'ai vu un
vous avez dû le voir aussi un
documentaire et ça me rend sur ce qui
vient de se faire à strasbourg là il ya
quelques villes qui commencent à avancer
mais il va falloir qu'on puisse avec nos
agents de cuisine
déjà qu'ils aient acceptation de leur
part parce que c'est tout de même on
change complètement les choses c'est à
dire comme ça c'est un poisson au fusil
on est en cours à montigny-le-bretonneux
pardon c'est un processus qui est en
cours a menti non parce que oui il ya
une chose que j'ai oublié de dire c'est
que comment est on a on a répondu à
cette question aux fédérations de
parents d'élèves les les barquettes
oui on peut les critiquer ceci étant on
est comme tout le monde et comme toute
ville
on respecte les normes c'est à dire que
le prestataire que nous avons respectent
les normes françaises qui elle même
tiens c'est tient ses normes des normes
européennes donc voilà donc vous restera
la fédé mais ceci dit oui on peut
entendre un plastique 10 à 30 ans a déjà
beaucoup évolué bon je me souviens que
je faisais des glaces à l'eau pour mes
enfants j'ai dû j'espère jeter les les
petits supports en question parce que le
voilà ces choses là ont évolué alors il
ya des solutions il allait jusqu'à on a
l'affairé bien longtemps qu'une petite
amie sur une petite conclusion notamment
pour vocation les solutions on va venir
tout le tape encore pour vous que je
peux juste finir parce que là c'est
votre
[Musique]
il ya effectivement plusieurs plusieurs
solutions il ya les barquettes
biodégradables et puis il ya le fait de
transférer les fameuses barquettes en
plastique qui arrive toute prête toutes
celles et c est qui et qui sont mises
dans les fours qui sont retirés des
fourrés qui sont servis sur chaque table
l'autre solution c'est donc de mettre
ses actuels barquettes qui arrive tel
quel ou de les vider dans des bacs en
inox de mettre ces bacs en inox qui ont
un pouvoir a quand même donc de mettre
ces bacs en inox dans les fours comme ça
se fait à l'heure actuelle il faut donc
ressortir les bacs qui sont lourds vous
allez voir que le 10 ans ils font
ressortir ses bagues qui se lance il
n'en a pas trop long mais je vais quand
même finir et puis ces bacs devant allez
donc sur un chariot et là il y aura deux
solutions soit de poser les bacs qui
sont chauds sur les tables ils sont
compacts sont en inox
voilà soi que les dames servent comme
autrefois les images d'epinal où on
servait à la louche dans les assiettes
c'est un vrai sujet aussi je pense qu'on
aura des maux de dos qui vont se
multiplier au niveau de nos agents
de service donc voilà c'est un vrai
sujet c'est pas un sujet qu'on a dû tout
l'éluder à montigné 1 on est on a
conscience est toujours en réflexion
petite conclusion 30 secondes notamment
sur wii même plus dire que
oui qu'on a un certain nombre
d'expériences qui existent notamment
dans les yvelines de communes ou de
lycée il ya deux lycéennes antique
bretonneux par exemple qui sont cette
démarche-là de produits bio locaux et
que du coup en tant que groupement
d'agriculteurs bio on est à la
disposition des collectivités pour voilà
répondre à leurs questions et essayer de
trouver des solutions au cas par cas
et voilà on pense que les les
collectivités locales ont un rôle à
jouer dans par ce biais là de la
commande publique dans la transition
agricole donc c'est positif sens et des
collectivités territoriales fallait bien
faire la démarche petite confusion
notamment ce que c'est possible parce
que lorsque c'est possible et nous on
est ouvert à la discussion en tout cas
sur elancourt on a des commissions menu
régulièrement auquel participent les
parents d'élèves donc on est ouvert la
discussion
je mets un bémol à tout ça qui est
encore d'une part et en premier l'aspect
financier de son souci et deuxièmement
l'aspect répondent aux besoins de tout
le monde tout le monde n'a pas un besoin
de manger bio ou voilà donc c'est un peu
compliqué pour nos collectivités je
rappelle que ce n'est pas une compétence
des communes la cantine on le fait bien
sûr et partout parce que sinon ce serait
ingérable des gens pourraient même pas
aller travailler
donc bien sûr on le fait mais mais avec
avec des contraintes et malheureusement
on est bien obligé de de ceux de se
borner à ce qu'on peut faire ou ne pas
faire
enfin cette fois de conclure moi je
dirais que c'est quand même possible
parce qu'il ya de plus en plus de villes
qui est qu'ils arrivent donc pourquoi
pas montigné il encourt y voit la montée
tout à fait merci beaucoup ce sera le
mot de la fin
quant à vous je vous invite à voir et
revoir cette émission sur notre site
internet sa chaussette se passent une
agréable soirée à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]
peu